what's up everybody zaki here from geek
culture bringing you another fantastic
episode of thirsty geek a series where
we show you how to make geeky inspired
drinks and cocktails from your favorite
shows movies and more
in this episode we will be making some
one division inspired drinks so buckle
up because these reality bending drinks
are going to rock your world
[Music]
and before we continue if you haven't
already support our channel by clicking
that subscribe button and giving us a
like
the first cocktail we're going to make
is simply a new york sour which is a
whiskey sour recipe with a float of
dried wine so starting with two ounces
of rye whiskey or bourbon so we're using
jack daniels here
into a mixing glass
next is
three quarter ounce of simple syrup
into the
glass
and what you want to do is take half of
a lemon
and what you're going to use is a
muddler or just squeeze
pretty much
an ounce to an ounce and a half of
freshly squeezed lemon juice make sure
you get all the juice in there
and we have one egg we're gonna only use
the egg whites for this
and this is to create a nice creamy foam
if you have problems you know eating raw
egg whites then this is totally optional
you can leave that out
i'm gonna put some ice into the mixing
glass and what you're gonna do is gonna
shake it real hard ryan went real hard
it's in chicken for a very long time
till the liquid turns nice and cloudy
all right
pop the bad boy open and what you're
gonna do is get a hawthorne strainer or
cocktail strainer looks like this as
well as a fine mesh strainer
and just set up your glass what you're
gonna do is gonna pour over the liquid
as well as the foam
like you see here do it with a height so
you can get some more aeration into the
liquid and what you wanna do is get all
the foam
in there just get all that foam we're
gonna hit it at the side
to sift all that foam onto the glass
what we have is a
just very fantastic bottle wine a dry
red wine but you can use pinot noir if
you want to get a more red color a
lighter red color this is a little bit
more like a burgundy but hey you know
this is what we got you got to use it so
an ounce or more if you like more wine
into your cocktail but we're using an
ounce here and what you want to do is
gently pull over
into the glass and what you want to have
is the color separation between the
whiskey sour
and the wine
on top of that i'm just dabbling a
little bit more wine so i can get the
foam to have that
wine color as well
and of course you're gonna have a taste
test you know because that's what ba
tenders do
last but not least
add a maraschino cherry
and you're gonna just cut a slit at the
bottom so you can slide it on the rim
of the glass and
yeah
voila this scarlet witch
enjoy
all right next up it's green it's yellow
and it's red you've guessed it we are
going to make a vision inspired cocktail
and what you want to get is a mini
watermelon if you can't find a mini
version you could use a regular sized
one just quadruple the ingredients and
you'll get a party size version to share
we recommend getting a seedless one if
not it's totally fine you can either
strain out the seeds after blending it
but we figure a little chunkiness would
add some nice texture to it so with that
we're going to cut both sides one
thicker than the other
and what you want to do is cut at least
two to three inches off the top and save
that for the lid
and just half an inch off the bottom so
we can get a nice flat surface to let
the watermelon sit on its own
scoop out as much watermelon bits as you
can and put it in a blender or a juicer
give it a whack until it's nice and
smooth
[Music]
and what you want to do next is two
ounces of hendrix gin
one ounce of sweet vermouth
fill the watermelon with ice
and pour over the blended watermelon
juice
have a sip feel good and
refreshing with a little punch at the
end
add some fruits we are using mango here
if you want to have a little bit more
sweetness you could blend the mango with
the watermelon chunks too and there you
have it this drink will give you a
vision of your favorite beach day
vacation
see what see what i did there right
right
[Music]
and finally a tribute to one of the
fastest x-men and it's also wonders
slash scarlet witch's brother
quicksilver
this almost clear blue turquoise drink
is quick to make and will give you a
boost in energy so that you can power
through your binge watching session
so first get a seat glass of your choice
fill it with ice and add one ounce of
very good tequila
we are using patron silver
get it
half an ounce of control or triple sec
two ounces of coconut water with pulp
and any blue colored energy slash sports
drink of your choice this recipe
actually calls for monster ultra blue
well we have blue gatorade for something
less sweet so one ounce of that and to
top it all off we have bose blue don't
let the color fool you it actually
tastes like fresh oranges so get a bar
spoon and
just drizzle a spoonful of that into the
glass
there you have it
the quicksilver
here we are my fellow geeks three
enjoyable wonder vision inspired drinks
that you can make at home
we hope you enjoyed this video and if
you did do give us a thumbs up and
support our channel by subscribing and
smashing that bell icon
to the next one this is zeki nasdorovia
[Music]